[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le mercredi 7 décembre voici le
programme valoriser les métiers méconnus
mais en lien avec le sport voici le but
de la journée organisé hier mardi 6
décembre au Centre national de football
de Clairefontaine au total une douzaine
de lycées étaient présents pour
découvrir des professions comme la
cybersécurité l'hôtellerie ou encore la
restauration des emplois qui contribuent
peut-être à la réussite des Bleus
aujourd'hui une caviste yvelinoise a
reçu le Rabelais des jeunes talents de
la gastronomie destiné à promouvoir des
professionnels de moins de 30 ans dans
le secteur de l'alimentation peri9
liposait démarquer parmi 250 candidats
nous reviendrons sur son parcours et
elle nous donnera également quelques
conseils à la défaites pour accorder son
vin à son dîner de réveillon et comme
chaque mercredi nous parlerons de cinéma
dans votre 7 8 au programme les sorties
dans les salles de cinéma et le coup de
cœur d'un professionnel du 7e art cette
semaine c'est le réalisateur Versailles
Gauthier Bara qui vous donnera son coup
de cœur et en plateau ce soir avec moi
Régine rallye bonsoir bonsoir
journaliste de la rédaction de TV 78
vous allez nous présenter les
informations d'aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines oui effectivement ben on va
parler de beaucoup de choses et
notamment de la hausse du prix du Pass
Navigo et ce sera dans quelques instants
je le disais à l'instant avec nous
également Perrine Philippot bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous avez été récompensé
par Le Rabelais des jeunes talents de la
gastronomie dans la catégorie caviste
qu'est-ce que ça représente ce prix
cette distinction bah ça représente une
récompense c'est un prix de notre
travail finalement c'est un peu la
cerise sur le gâteau comme je dis
souvent puisque c'est un métier de
passion donc c'est un petit plus et ça
fait plaisir
on en parlera plus en détail tout à
l'heure nous sommes aussi accompagnés de
Marie-Laure Pouliquen bonsoir bonsoir
c'est un plateau très féminin ce soir
vous pratiquez une technique de massage
qui se nomme le Gestalt ça va pas être
facile à prononcer d'ailleurs c'est le
titre de votre conférence qui aura lieu
demain le gostalt massage le massage un
nom un prononçable alors est-ce que
c'est quoi exactement le le gestal tout
simplement c'est de la relation d'être
par le toucher où il y a aussi de la
parole et qui est dérivée donc de la
guste althérapie qui est une
psychothérapie donc pareil on en
reviendra on reviendra un peu plus en
détail tout à l'heure mais avant je vous
propose de regarder la météo de demain
demain matin nous devrions avoir un
temps hivernal dans les Yvelines le ciel
devrait être brumeux sur l'ensemble du
département au niveau des températures
il fera 1 degré à Mantes-la-Jolie
Versailles et Houdain et comptez 0° à
Rambouillet alors couvrez-vous bien dans
l'après-midi le ciel devrait rester
couvert au niveau des températures
comptées 4 degrés à Mantes-la-Jolie 3
degrés à Versailles et aux dents et 2
degrés à Rambouillet maintenant sur
l'actualité dans les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Régina ralech on
commence par le chiffre du jour 84 10 et
virgule 10 centimes d'euros
effectivement à compter du 1er janvier
2023 le forfait mensuel du passe Navigo
passera de 75 € 20 à 80 4 euros et 10
centimes ce matin plusieurs centaines de
personnes se sont rassemblées au siège
d'Île-de-France mobilité à Saint-Ouen
pour contester ses décisions le Parti
communiste en Île-de-France avait lancé
la semaine dernière une pétition
intitulée stop la galère contre la
hausse du prix du Pass Navigo et pour je
cite une meilleure qualité de service
alors comment expliquer cette hausse
alors plusieurs raisons ont été énoncées
entre autres l'inflation et la hausse
exceptionnelle du coup de l'énergie mais
ceci comprend également le budget
d'investissement nécessaire au maintien
du matériel roulant à ce titre Clément
Beaune le ministre des Transports a
évoqué que le gouvernement débloquerait
une aide exceptionnelle de 200 millions
d'euros à Île-de-France
de mobilité pardon pour éviter un tarif
mensuel à 90 euros et on continue avec
de nouveaux modes de recrutement régime
effectivement donc de nouveaux modes de
recrutement innovants ont été organisés
hier donc mardi 6 décembre au complexe
Jacques Moncaut à Trappes Pôle emploi il
l'association faite le maire spécialisé
dans l'insertion par le sport proposé un
job dating sportif pour les demandeurs
d'emploi
issus de quartiers prioritaires en quoi
ça consiste alors du coup l'événement se
déroulait en deux parties une première
ou des demandeurs d'emploi et des
recruteurs s'affrontés sur les 7 et une
seconde avec des cours d'entretien alors
vous l'aurez compris l'idée de faire
émerger le savoir-être l'esprit d'équipe
et aussi de casser les codes de
recrutement traditionnel on reviendra
plus longuement sur cette opération dans
la semaine et donc cette opération
s'appelle faites le mur non je sais et
sport je sais et sport exactement
toujours côté entreprise Régine vous
allez nous parler d'un événement qui a
lieu hier à Mantes-la-Jolie oui midi de
la création événement qui permet
d'accompagner des entrepreneurs se
tenaient au cinéma CGR de la ville au
travers de différents ateliers
thématiques des créateurs et repreneurs
ont pu se rencontrer et ont pu également
rencontrer des experts de la création
d'entreprises comme des comptables et
également des organismes de financement
le but répondre aux questions des
porteurs de projets et leur proposer un
accompagnement personnalisé on écoute
Guillaume Kerrou le président de la
Chambre de Commerce et de l'Industrie
Versailles Yvelines l'un des
organisateurs de l'événement on avait
une centaine de personnes les attentes
sont assez diverses quel secteur dans
quel secteur s'orienter vers ou
s'orienter pour les pour financer son
projet par quoi commencer à partir du
moment où on a une idée donc là on
retrouve l'ensemble des partenaires à la
création d'entreprise qui sont tous
présents les commerçants et
l'association des commerçants demandent
de réseau initiative les grandes banques
bien évidemment et l'ensemble des grands
partenaires à la création d'entreprise
on a tous l'écosystème entrepreneurial
présent sur cet après midi la création
d'entreprise
l'association equalys qui a pour but
d'accompagner les personnes les plus
démunies et dans la tourmente après des
polémiques sur les malversations
financières de l'ex-directeur
l'association souffre de grandes
difficultés une quarantaine de postes
sont menacées et dans les Yvelines
plusieurs services sont fermés dont les
bergement d'urgence pour demandeurs
d'asile de Louveciennes le service
prévention ville de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine et l'espace
d'insertion professionnelle de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et on termine
ces informations du jour par une
victoire oui celle du Maroc face à
l'Espagne hier soir l'effervescence
était à son comble à 18h30 à
Mantes-la-Jolie des centaines de
personnes se sont réunies pour célébrer
la victoire marocaine des drapeaux et
des pancartes défilés sur lesquels on
pouvait lire Maroc la jolie il y a
néanmoins eu de léger débordements ce
qui a généré des retards et des
déviations sur les lignes de bus de la
ville merci beaucoup Régine rélès et si
vous aussi comme d'habitude vous voyez
une information qui vous a marqué près
de chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
communiquer en utilisant le hashtag 78
news
[Musique]
pendant un mois des enseignants se sont
rendus dans des entreprises yvelinoises
le but
identifier des pistes concrètes d'emploi
pour leurs élèves une initiative de la
Fondation c'est génial avec nous pour en
parler Anne border bonsoir
bonsoir le premier décembre une dizaine
d'enseignants se sont rendus chez
anté-méta une entreprise spécialisée
notamment dans la protection des données
alors comment ça s'est passé
concrètement
ça c'est très bien passé
comme toutes les visites de la Fondation
c'est génial qui vont les enseignants
étaient inquiétés
au sein
des enseignants donc l'idée
de l'entreprise et notamment de bien
comprendre les filières
orienter les jeunes
c'est aussi se mettre en contact le
métier
c'est vrai que le parcours
de découvrir au travers
des
personnes qui étaient de collaborateurs
qui est tel que
des milliers de travaux
à chacun de
[Musique]
alors on vous entend pas très bien
aborder on va essayer de poursuivre
cette interview un peu mieux pourquoi
avoir lancé cette initiative des
professeurs au sein des entreprises
alors cette initiative elle existe c'est
une initiative c'est une un pilier de la
une action de la Fondation c'est génial
la Fondation c'est géniale qui a 16 ans
qu'on renouvelle tous les ans au mois de
novembre la semaine de l'entreprise il
s'agit de
son entreprise qui sont qui ont ouvert
la porte d'enseignants deux collèges et
de lycées et vraiment l'objectif c'est
que les enseignants de collège lycée
viennent
au contact de l'entreprise
les filières
c'est une des actions de la Fondation
notre la Fondation elle a pour mission
de susciter l'intérêt des collectifs
pour les sciences et les techniques et
le numérique au travers justement de
la valorisation de ces métiers ça
facilite l'orientation des élèves je
suppose par la suite alors oui ça montre
aux élèves que avec des sciences et des
maths ça mène à pas mal de métiers et
effectivement ça les aide à connaître
votre métier qui est aujourd'hui
tellement de métiers qui sont pas connus
des jeunes et nous
imaginer grâce à l'action professeur en
entreprise que c'était les enseignants
avaient besoin en fait de s'informer
pour partager avec
merci Anne boire des je le rappelle vous
êtes chargés des partenariats et mécénat
pour la Fondation c'est génial et on
continue de parler d'orientation et
d'emploi dans le cadre de la Semaine des
lycées professionnels le Centre national
de football de Clairefontaine donnait
hier ce mardi 6 décembre plusieurs
tables rondes le but faire connaître des
métiers méconnus en lien avec le sport
le reportage du régime ralech ce mardi 6
décembre collégiens lycéen et enseignant
se sont réunis à Clairefontaine dans le
centre national de football le but
découvrir et valoriser les métiers de la
filière professionnelle en lien avec le
sport alors aujourd'hui les élèves
lycéens il y a une douzaine de lycées
représentés avec donc 12 formations sur
la sécurité sur l'accueil de la
maintenance sur de la cybersécurité sur
de la vente et en fait c'est de montrer
qu'il y a des métiers en lien avec le
sport qui sont un petit peu cachés et
qui contribuent à la réussite peut-être
des Bleus aujourd'hui pour donner envie
ce sont des lycéens de filières
professionnelles qui mènent les ateliers
de découverte ici ce sont les métiers de
la sécurité qui sont expliqués gendarmes
policier ou bodyguard pour les
célébrités comme les joueurs de football
de quoi séduire les élèves ça nous ouvre
plusieurs portes et ça nous change de la
générale
quelques personnes qui veulent qui
savent pas ce qu'ils veulent faire plus
tard la filière professionnelle pour moi
elle est hyper intéressante parce que on
peut accéder à plusieurs plusieurs
formations ou plusieurs débouchés donc
dans plusieurs métiers sous-estimez pour
certains manque de visibilité pour
d'autres la filière professionnelle
souffrirait d'une mauvaise image elle a
pourtant connu une évolution depuis la
crise sanitaire et certains élèves
manifesteraient même un certain intérêt
malheureusement je pense qu'on est trop
dans le le classique lycée classique
seconde générale je pense que le milieu
professionnel est pas assez mis en
valeur au niveau des des élèves et
surtout peut-être même au niveau des
parents en 2021 72% des apprentis de
niveau CAP à BTS occupait un emploi
salarié dans le secteur privé deux ans
après leur sortie d'études soit 5% de
plus que l'année précédente
on en parlait en début d'émission
Perrine Flipo vous avez été récompensé
par Le Rabelais des jeunes talents de la
gastronomie dans la catégorie caviste
alors vous êtes également responsable du
magasin de la Vignerie à Guyancourt
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez décidé de
vous lancer dans ce concours pour se
mesurer déjà au plus grand forcément
puisque quand on est jeune quand on est
une femme on n'est pas forcément
le cliché entre guillemets du caviste
donc c'est toujours c'est toujours
marrant de se confronter à des confrères
ou des concerts d'ailleurs ce qu'on
était quand même quelques femmes dans le
concours donc
c'est cool et voilà pour ce challenge
aussi un petit peu et en apprendre
toujours plus sur notre métier alors on
sait que ça c'est plutôt bien passé pour
vous vu que vous avez fini lauréate mais
comment ça s'est déroulé concrètement
alors en fait j'ai pas vraiment fini
l'oréade puisque il y a trois étapes à
ce concours la première et est un
questionnaire en ligne finalement de
10 questions c'est les questions
QCM et des questions ouvertes et à la
suite de ça du coup on passe à la
deuxième étape où là c'est un
questionnaire sur table une dégustation
à l'aveugle également
et après il y a une troisième étape que
cette année je n'ai pas je n'ai pas
faite mais peut-être dans deux ans on y
verra c'est quoi cette troisième étape
troisième étape c'est la même chose
finalement des questions donc de culture
sur le vin sur les alcools etc un sketch
de vente et tout ça sur une scène devant
plein de gens
et donc c'est un objectif pour plus tard
bah bien sûr
vous êtes quand même démarqué parmi 250
candidats environ qu'est-ce qui a fait
la différence selon vous bah les
connaissances probablement effectivement
c'est beaucoup de travail c'est c'est
voilà d'apprendre toujours plus sur
plein de choses et a priori j'ai eu des
bonnes réponses à cette première étape
est-ce que vous vous avez rencontré des
difficultés des obstacles ah bah oui
c'est c'est comme tout concours et comme
tout examen finalement ça dépend de sur
quoi on tombe en fonction de ce qu'on a
révisé le monde du vin et des spiritueux
est tellement vaste que on peut pas tout
apprendre en quelques mois c'est un
travail un peu toute une vie donc si
vous avez 20 questions et que c'est pas
tomber sur ce que vous avez appris bah
tant pis
et en tant que que femme parce que bon
le milieu du vin c'est quand même un
milieu d'homme est-ce que vous avez eu
des difficultés pas par rapport au
concours puisque c'est anonyme mais mais
oui effectivement on n'est pas encore
une fois le cliché du caviste auquel on
pense dans un premier temps mais voilà
ce d'être arrivé en qualification
d'avoir eu ce prix Rabelais ça me donne
aussi un petit peu de de force et un
petit peu de crédibilité siège puis dire
face à mes clients derrière d'où vous
vient cette passion du vin
un peu naturellement finalement j'ai mes
grands-parents d'un côté qui sont
bordelais de l'autre côté qui sont
Bourguignons finalement forcément ça
fait des beaux mélanges ils sont
exactement mais sans être spécialement
de grands passionnés de grands amateurs
mais il y a effectivement
toujours une belle bouteille à table la
petite histoire qui va bien parce que
c'est ça aussi le vent c'est pas juste
de l'alcool c'est toute l'histoire qui a
derrière tout le travail qu'il y a
derrière il y a tout un tas de petites
personnes qui
œuvrent tout au long de l'année pour
vous régaler dans tous les moments de
votre vie et vous avez effectué un stage
de six mois en Afrique du Sud alors
comment ça se fait que vous avez pu
partir en Afrique du Sud et surtout
qu'est-ce que vous avez appris là-bas
alors j'ai appris plein de choses
notamment l'anglais c'est pas
négligeable j'ai appris qu'on faisait du
vin un peu partout dans le monde de
manière différente avec des goûts
différents et des cultures différentes
finalement et j'ai pu partir à
l'occasion d'un stage
finalement qui était obligatoire
en école de commerce il fallait partir 6
mois à l'étranger dans un pays
anglophone et naturellement je me suis
tourné vers vers l'Afrique du Sud et ses
beaux paysages et c'est bon vin
forcément c'est une expérience
enrichissante évidemment alors à
l'approche des fêtes de fin d'année
est-ce que vous avez des conseils pour
nos téléspectateurs s'ils souhaitent
associer un vin à un mais qu'ils ont
préparé bon évidemment on a toujours
plein de conseils ils sont les bienvenus
en boutique et évidemment sur Guyancourt
après ça dépend du plat ça dépend de
leur goût aussi nous notre travail c'est
justement d'aller à leur dénicher des
petites pépites pour qu'ils passent un
bon moment en famille ou entre amis on
regorge d'idées et on adore y réfléchir
par exemple pour le foie gras avec quoi
on peut accompagner le foie gras le
traditionnel Sauterne fonctionne
toujours
si on n'est pas trop vin sucré on peut
très bien partir sur un vin rouge on
peut faire des accords un petit peu
originaux qui changent de l'ordinaire et
on peut quand même se régaler si on
souhaite plutôt de la viande un chapon
un chapon un petit Bourgogne on se
refait pas ça marche toujours bien le
pinot noir
mais on peut aussi partir sur sur un
Bordeaux en fonction de comment il est
farcir en fonction de son accompagnement
on a mille et une possibilité en
fonction de ce qu'on a dans la tête et
si on est plutôt poisson du coup et si
on est plutôt poisson
on fait tout poisson Saint-Jacques
fruits de mer on peut partir sur un joli
blanc un mène tout en Val de Loire ça
marche très bien ou un chablis si on
reste en Bourgogne et bien merci
beaucoup Perrine Clipo d'être venu en
plateau je le rappelle vous êtes
responsable du magasin de la vigne russe
la Vignery située à Guyancourt dans
l'actualité également demain jeudi 8
décembre se tiendra la rentrée
solennelle à la faculté de endroit et de
sciences politiques chaque année cette
cérémonie récompense les étudiants major
de promo on écoute l'interview de Franck
Monnier Ledoyen de la faculté au micro
de Régine ralech
[Musique]
la tradition de la rentrée solennelle
remonte à une quinzaine d'années je
crois que j'ouvrirai la 16e édition de
la rentrée solennelle c'est pour nous
l'occasion de remettre des distinctions
à nos majors de promotion c'est un
diplôme de major particulier que l'on
remet aux étudiants les plus méritants
c'est l'occasion aussi pour nous de le
remettre des ouvrages pour les aider à
approfondir leurs cours et anticiper les
matières qu'ils suivront les années
suivantes
[Musique]
le doyen lors de cette rentrée
solennelle a pour rôle de faire le bilan
de l'année qui vient de s'achever et de
faire le point sur les projets en cours
il y a des projets évidemment de
développement de nos formations
notamment orientées vers les doubles
licences il y a le chantier qui
s'annonce autour de la sélection des
étudiants en Master 1 il y a également
des projets beaucoup plus originaux de
développement de la proposition
culturelle à nos étudiants notamment en
lien avec les cinémas les théâtres du
département et c'est dans les tablettes
également avec la presse
[Musique]
connaissez-vous le Gestalt autour du
plateau pas du tout pas du tout rien du
tout et bien c'est une technique de
massage qui aide à faire ressortir les
émotions et avec nous pour en parler
Marie-Laure Pouliquen vous pratiquez ce
massage alors comment ça se passe
concrètement une séance de ce massage
mais ça se passe en trois temps le
premier temps c'est une discussion donc
je pose le cadre bienveillance non
jugement et puis les personnes amènent
les problématiques qu'elles ont assez
variées en général et puis j'explique
comment vont se passer la séance donc ce
premier temps de parole lors de la
première séance va se demande quand même
au niveau du corps s'il y a des
antécédents comment la personne se sent
dans son corps et vraiment pour la
personne se sent à l'aise de choisir de
se dévêtir ou pas puisque c'est un
massage qui peut aussi se pratiquer
habillée et puis après deuxième temps la
partie massage à proprement parler
et à la suite de ça un petit temps de
séparation parce que le massage quand
même c'est quelque chose d'assez
fusionnelle on est vraiment en plein
contact donc pour que chacun reprenne sa
place et là un petit débriefing de
comment ça s'est passé pour la personne
et donc ça dure combien de temps une
séance alors il y a la version bien-être
de qui dure une heure et la version
accompagnement relation d'aide qui dure
1h30 et du coup quels sont les gestes et
les mouvements que vous faites
concrètement pour aider les personnes
pour les accompagner mais c'est des
gestes variés donc il y a des étirements
il y a de la partie purement massage il
y a des
gestes autour de la respiration donc
c'est il y a un panel assez varié et
puis quelques gestes spécifiques
effectivement pour aller travailler sur
la globalité du corps puisque c'est
vraiment une des spécificités on
travaille en même temps sur le corps
mais aussi sur la partie plus psy donc
quelque chose de global de se sentir
bien dans son corps bien dans sa peau
dans qui on est et du coup quels sont
quels sont les bienfaits se sentir mieux
dans son corps mais ce qui a d'autres
bienfaits ça reconnecta la à sa joie sa
confiance en soi à la sécurité dans
cette période où on est un petit peu
insécu on sait pas très bien ce qui se
passe entre Poutine le prix de l'essence
enfin plein de choses il y a quand même
beaucoup d'insécurité et revenir sur son
corps se sentir vraiment dans l'issue et
maintenant
j'aurais juste mon question
c'est quelle langue aussi alors c'est de
l'allemand la gusta le thérapie a été
inventée par Fred sperme ce qui est qui
vient d'Allemagne mais qui a fait un
petit tour par l'Afrique du Sud pour
après aller aux États-Unis
alors que je tel c'est un peu compliqué
à expliquer en deux trois mots je
pourrais juste dire que une séance c'est
un cycle du contact on commence par se
rencontrer par la vue par la parole
après par le toucher
et la salle devient du plein contact et
puis après on se resserre voilà et donc
là que je tal c'est
comme une boucle comme un cycle du
contact qui a un début et une fin donc
on fait vraiment très attention quand
j'entre en contact avec l'autre et
comment se sépare c'est vraiment
travailler sur un massage relationnel
comment je suis avec les autres et en
général ce qui se passe donc en séance
de massage c'est ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur et peut-être qu'il se passe
pas très bien à l'extérieur cette
technique de massage elle a été prouvée
scientifiquement alors scientifiquement
je peux pas dire ça par contre
effectivement comme c'est dérivés
lingostalthérapie qui est une
psychothérapie réputée dans le monde
entier il y a un monde d'expérience et
ça a été décliné puisque c'est vraiment
le cycle du contact cette guste
althérapie ça a vraiment été décliné
logiquement avec du massage et de toute
façon le l'homme a besoin de toucher
on voit bien les bébés qui ne se
développent pas s'il y a pas de toucher
avec la covid on a été quand même
vraiment en manque de toucher et on voit
bien ce que ça fait sur les personnes
âgées notamment sur les jeunes mais sur
nous aussi c'est vrai que voilà c'est il
y a quelque chose de fondamental dans le
toucher et donc pour ça c'est vraiment
se reconnecter à
un lien profond d'attachement de
sécurité de bien-être et justement quels
sont quelles sont les problématiques que
vous rencontrez la plupart du temps
venant de vos patients alors c'est très
varié ça peut être bon des violences
sexuelles ça peut être une image du
corps donc problème d'obésité par
exemple
ça peut être tout simplement ben je
comprends pas j'ai un mari j'ai des
enfants j'ai une maison j'ai un boulot
tout va bien et pourtant tout va bien
donc il y a aussi beaucoup de personnes
qui viennent sur des choses où il y a
pas un problème identifié et c'est
ensemble on va progressivement voir ce
qui se passe j'imagine
j'imagine que c'est un suivi ça peut
être un massage comme Plusieurs massages
durant une longue période bah alors il
faut au moins 5 massages à 15 jours 3
semaines d'écart et puis là pendant
voilà cinq c'est pas mal déjà parce que
mon travail sur la mémoire du corps il y
a tout un des gestes qui sont toujours
les mêmes et puis avec des choses
différentes dedans donc pour que le
corps s'habitue et que la confiance
s'installe aussi entre nous parce que on
est quand même dans l'intimité on est
dans le corps donc faut vraiment que les
choses s'installe progressivement et à
ce moment là après voilà ça
ça peut produire quelque chose et j'ai
beaucoup de personnes qui font un cycle
donc 5 10 séances qui s'arrêtent et qui
progressivement
comprennent à quel moment ils auraient
besoin d'une séance pour se reconnecter
à sa joie intérieure sa confiance en soi
se ressentir en sécurité et donc voilà
c'est il faut un certain nombre de
séances et puis après effectivement
les gens reviennent plus pour
piqûres de rappel pour se poser et donc
demain vous donner une conférence sur
sur ce sujet sur ce massage c'est
accessible à tous oui c'est accessible à
tous donc ça a lieu à Andrésy dans
l'association Confluence donc vous
pouvez voir toutes les informations sur
mon site web et mails.fr et oui c'est
pendant une heure je lui ai expliqué
donc plus en détail vraiment les tout ce
qui vient de la gusta le thérapie et qui
vient alimenter donc ce massage vraiment
dans cette bien traitance cette
attention la relation ça vous donne
envie de tester autour du plateau
Perrine Flippo
autrement je peux vous recommander
d'autres collègues dans le coin
effectivement et bien merci beaucoup
Marie-Laure pulgaine d'être venu en
parler avec nous merci de m'avoir
invités cette semaine nous vous
proposons une série de reportages sur le
chef cuisinier Jérémy en bielle du
restaurant de l'arche dans l'épisode 1
et 2 nous l'avons suivi chez ses
producteurs favoris du pays ou d’années
bouché primeur aujourd'hui il part à la
rencontre d'un éleveur de poules et plus
spécialement de poules de Houdan le
reportage de Nicolas dandry
salut tout le monde
chercher la commande pour aujourd'hui
est prêt puis quand le haché
normalement il y a tout ce qu'il faut
[Musique]
les oignons poireaux parfait c'est top
salut Julien salut ça va ça va et toi
nickel bon je suis venu chercher les
poules de Houdan pour pouvoir faire la
poule au pot et puis j'aurais bien aimé
pouvoir faire un tour avec toi que tu
m'expliquais un petit peu ta façon
d'élever les volailles
tu montrerais un petit peu les arrières
et j'aimerais bien comprendre un peu
plus on va aller voir ça
je vais te faire voir les reproducteurs
que j'ai
des poules ensemble qui me servent à
faire des œufs pour pouvoir produire des
poussins moi-même d'accord
[Musique]
j'ai un petit Châtel de reproducteur
qu'on a sélectionné surtout pour la pour
la masse d'accord alors on essaie de
bien garder les critères de beauté elles
sont belles
donc faut bien là houpette après faut
pas trop de noir pas trop de blanc alors
après les spécialistes connaissent mieux
que moi il y a un nombre de plumes à
respecter et tout mais moi je m'occupe
surtout du poids et de la chair tu peux
regarder elle est très lourde
mais je trouve que pour une ou deux ans
c'est très lourd
ça fait son poids j'ai une couveuse avec
des œufs en train de couver une couveuse
un éclosoir avec une éclosion en cours
et après j'ai des poussins en train de
démarrer
[Musique]
c'est bien de voir justement que il y a
des personnes comme toi qui qui
travaillent sur sur la continuité du
d'une poule comme la poule de Houdan qui
est aujourd'hui est difficile à élever
[Musique]
donc il y a quatre semaines ils étaient
comme les petits qu'on a vu dans la
couveuse
ils sont bons à consommer à partir de 5
mois et demi à peu près quoi là j'en ai
des Houdan là j'en ai 280 vous le faire
ça pour me démarquer un peu puis je me
disais tiens je suis dans le secteur de
Houdan je trouvais ça une bonne idée
Manu l'objectif du restaurant c'est la
même c'est faire en sorte que cette race
continue à vivre et c'est de la mettre à
l'honneur sur la table
bon je vais récupérer ma commande du
coup ouais bah bien elle est prête elle
est là et puis on va aller cuisiner tout
ça OK
[Musique]
et le dernier épisode sera à découvrir
demain le chef cuisinier à Jérémy en
bielle nous présentera sa recette de
poule au pot dans l'émission PAF Patrice
carmouz recevait Raphaël Costa auteur
d'un livre à la fois instructif et très
drôle le procès du Père Noël il s'agit
d'un vrai procès avec des charges comme
violation de domicile travail forcé des
lutins ou encore mauvais traitement des
animaux avec une enquête un réquisitoire
des plaidoiries et des témoins dont un
assez étonnant celui de Vladimir Poutine
qui se veut l'avocate du père Noël
regardez Vladimir Poutine est très
copain avec le Père Noël oui donc il
vient témoigne au procès lui a porté son
soutien en visio puisqu'il peut pas il
préfère pas se rendre
dans une cours française et en fait
c'est parce qu'il y a une vraie affaire
en Russie avec un avocat de
Saint-Pétersbourg qui a porté plainte
contre la société russe qui gère le
village du Père Noël et il estime que
depuis qu'il est enfant il a envoyé des
listes de cadeaux à cette société comme
les gens envoient en France à Libourne
par la poste leur liste au Père Noël et
il a jamais reçu les cadeaux donc il a
porté plainte contre cette société en
donc l'année dernière et Poutine a été
interrogé là-dessus en conférence de
presse il y a 2 ans et il a dit que
l'avocat du Père Noël c'était lui donc
il allait prendre sa défense en France
déjà été son avocat et par contre rien
n'est inventé la tête et donc d'accord
tout est vrai tout est vrai et donc même
ils ont proposé enfin il voulait que il
voulait le professeur notre nom et
cetera alors du coup ça c'est en fait
dans le livre on apprend aussi la
tradition du Père Noël en Russie qui est
différente de la du Père Noël français
déjà il habite en bleu il s'appelle
différemment donc Poutine explique tout
ça mais il explique aussi cette vraie
affaire gel ouais
et donc il se balade en calèche je sais
pas en traîneau avec des rennes et
Poutine raconte cette affaire il
explique que si c'est avocat n'a pas eu
de cadeaux il a qu'à s'en prendre qu'à
lui-même ce qu'il a pas été assez sage
donc pour l'instant on n'a pas encore eu
le jugement dans la ferme mais tout ça
tout est vrai toutes les déclarations de
Poutine sont vraies
et vous pourrez retrouver l'intégralité
de cette interview sur notre site
Internet et nos réseaux sociaux
prochainement
[Musique]
comme chaque mercredi c'est le moment de
notre page cinéma et on a été rejoint au
plateau par Grégory canalet journaliste
de la rédaction de TV 78 bonsoir bonsoir
Mathieu bonsoir à toutes vous allez nous
parler des sorties dans les salles de
cinéma aujourd'hui oui on va commencer
avec un nouveau film nouveau film du
réalisateur d'indigènes je vous en dis
un mot tout de suite allez donc il
s'agit de Rachid Bouchareb qui revient
avec son dernier long-métrage nos
frangins au casting on retrouve Redakai
Blida coût de riz ou encore Raphaël
Personnaz nos frangins nous propose un
retour en arrière dans la nuit du 5 au 6
décembre 1986 de Français d'origine
algérienne Malikou sekin et Abdel
benahia sont assassinés suite à des
interventions de police le ministère de
l'Intérieur tente alors d'étouffer
l'affaire le film revient sur
l'indignation de l'époque face aux
méthodes policières et aux réactions
politiques vous allez nous parler d'un
autre film à présent un film français
maestro maestro alors chez les Dumas on
est chef d'orchestre de père en fils
mais entre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas le fils que t'aurais rêvé
avoir
si tu passes à côté de ça tu te
remettras pas
[Musique]
et du côté du cinéma international vous
avez sélectionné un film sud-coréen
Grégory
il s'agit d'IRO à kazoo coréena Palme
d'Or 2018 à Cannes pour une affaire de
famille là le film dont je vous parle
c'est les bonnes étoiles à l'affiche
notamment l'acteur sud-coréen son Kango
qu'on a vu aussi récemment dans une
palme d'or en 2019 à Cannes dans
parasite les bonnes étoiles suit deux
trafiquants qui volent et revendre des
bébés au marché noir par une nuit plus
vieux une jeune femme abandonne son bébé
il est récupéré par les deux courtiers
mais la mer va changer finalement d'avis
et tout s'associent pour trouver une
famille idéale on parle ici d'un sujet
assez grave mais qui est traitée avec
finesse et humour comme tout comme quoi
tout est possible et le dernier c'est un
film tout public c'est la suite des
aventures du Chat Potté el chapotait le
célèbre chat à l'accent espagnol et ses
bottes que l'on avait connu dans Shrek
et qui a eu le droit à son premier
spin-off c'était en 2011 là c'est donc
la suite le chat c'est deux la dernière
quête la passion pour l'aventure de
potée et son hardi son hardiesse ont eu
raison de lui il a épuisé et huit de ses
9 vies de chats le problème c'est qu'il
en avait perdu le compte au passage le
petit personnage va se lancer donc dans
la quête de l'étoile aveu pour gagner en
longévité problème le grand méchant loup
Boucle d'Or qui dirige le gang des trois
ours et Big Jack Horner veulent s'en
emparer aussi mais potée va pouvoir
compter sur le soutien de sa fidèle
complice Kitty a pas de velours et de
perdre un adorable petit chien toujours
très enthousiaste petit extrait de la
bande-annonce
ce sera juste parfait
[Musique]
mercado dont les voix originales on ne
change pas une équipe qui gagne on
retrouve Antonio Banderas c'est Salma
Hayek merci beaucoup Grégory canalet des
préférences autour du plateau le film
préféré peut-être le Chat Potté le Chat
Potté
ce film juste pour ça et vous Grégory
une préférence peut-être moi j'adore le
personnage du Chat Potté après je
m'intéresse beaucoup aussi au fait de
société au fait d'histoire et c'est vrai
que le film Nos frangin le dernier film
du réalisateur d'indigène m'intéresse
aussi tout autant dans un registre
différent mais oui s'il y a une
préférence à donner on va dire le Chat
Potté pour le côté sourire et pour un
personnage que j'apprécie
particulièrement
super et je vous propose de poursuivre
cette page cinéma avec le coup de coeur
d'un professionnel du 7e art cette
semaine c'est Gauthier Bara le
réalisateur versaillé qui vous propose
son coup de coeur regardez
[Musique]
capitaine fantastique donc c'est un film
de Matros qui est sorti en 2016 ici
c'est un film où le héros est humain on
ne parle pas d'un super héros comme
Batman comme Superman ou Iron Man mais
ici l'humain à part entière est un héros
au sens naturel on va glorifier la
différence des humains des humains qui
vivent dans la forêt et des humains qui
vivent en ville vie comme Mortensen donc
le père de la famille va élever donc ses
enfants avec sa femme dans la forêt et
va devoir faire face en fait à la ville
au cours d'une tragique histoire ici du
coup on va faire face à des enfants qui
ne connaissent rien bien à la ville rien
en l'amour rien en à la sociabilité des
gens et du coup on va voir des scènes
d'humour todrôles des fois malaisant et
des fois un peu plus tragique du coup on
est vraiment sur le coeur ils ont des
hot-dogs
qui parlent également de l'amendement de
la Constitution des États-Unis qui la
connaissent par cœur face à des enfants
qui sortent du bac qui ne connaissent
rien du tout ça qui est assez drôle on
est vraiment sur des propos très simples
c'est un film qui a du corps de la
volonté du cœur et on peut vraiment
parler du sens de la famille
[Musique]
et la semaine prochaine dans notre page
cinéma nous parlerons d'Avatar puisque
c'est un film à ne pas manquer
le dernier né de James Cameron la suite
de l'opus de 2009 qui est peut-être l'un
des films les plus attendus on parlait
souvent d'un manque de fréquentation des
salles de cinéma là on pourra jauger
pour voir si un gros bloc Buster tel
avatar Avatar 2 la voix de l'eau réatire
le public au cinéma en tout cas le film
annoncé comme le film de 2022 pour cette
fin d'année
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant de se quitter je vous
propose de regarder la météo de demain
matin nous devrions avoir un temps
hivernal le ciel devrait être brumeux
sur l'ensemble du département au niveau
des températures il fera 1 degré à
Mantes-la-Jolie Versailles et aux dents
et comptez 0° à Rambouillet alors
couvrez-vous bien dans l'après-midi le
ciel devrait rester couvert au niveau
des températures comptées 4 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie 3 degrés à Versailles et
Houdan les deux degrés à Rambouillet et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi jusqu'au bout avec nous je
vous souhaite une belle soirée sur TV 78
prenez soin de vous
[Musique]